24 horas es lo que ha durado este último
enfrentamiento entre Israel y las
milicias palestinas de gaza que tuvo
como detonante la muerte del preso
palestino en una cárcel israelí después
de pasar 86 días en huelga de hambre
antes del amanecer Egipto Qatar y
Naciones Unidas mediaron para que se
alcanzara un alto el fuego que llega
tras un total de 104 cohetes lanzados
desde la franja y dos tandas de
bombardeos nocturnos de Israel sobre 16
supuestas instalaciones del grupo jamás
entre ellas fábricas y almacenes de
armas y túneles y campos de
entrenamiento además de grabar la
situación del enclave gazatti uno de sus
ataques aéreos israelíes causó que una
piedra cayera sobre el pecho de un
hombre de 58 años que dormía junto a su
hijo y que murió horas después por en
una hemorragia interna según el
Ministerio de salud de la franja otros
cinco palestinos sufrieron heridas
mientras que previamente en la ciudad
israelí de esderot tres obreros de
nacionalidad china también resultaron
heridos por la metralla de un cohete
palestino
Más allá de La tregua el líder político
de jamás Así como el comité
Internacional de la Cruz Roja han
reclamado a Israel que entrega el cuerpo
de jader andan referente dentro de la
yihad islámica Palestina y primer preso
palestino en huelga de hambre que muere
bajo custodia israelí en más de 30 años
a la vez el Primer Ministro Benjamín
netanyahu enfrenta críticas del ala más
radical de su coalición de gobierno el
partido poder judío del ministro de
seguridad y tamamar benhibir tildó los
bombardeos en gaza de respuesta débil y
otra ministra de extrema derecha orit
strok dio a entender que Israel Tendría
que haber destruido varios rascacielos
en gaza y matado a más terroristas